we're here in the forests a few
kilometers away from the contested town
of liman now we were here a few days ago
and things have changed quite
dramatically since then
russian forces are now in full control
of a village
to my left a few kilometers in that
direction a town called zaryjne
they are also contesting another village
called yampil what they are trying to do
is take full control of luman from the
ukrainian forces that as i say are a few
kilometers in that direction and push
south
towards slavyans now we've been here
about an hour there have been volley
after volley
of incoming and outgoing
shells
you can hear another one there
and this shelling is getting closer and
closer to slavyansk
another shell explodes close by
but incredibly not a single house has
been hit in the next village down the
road but it is only a few kilometers
away from the slowly advancing russian
army
children play on bikes in the evening
sun
a gentle stroll down the lane by the
church
life is almost disturbingly normal on
the surface
all our family is here so we don't want
to live we are all from this village our
life is here
many of our friends have left but many
of them want to come home because they
miss their life in the village
we hope everything will be okay and they
go somewhere else or turn around and not
come back
from the top of a nearby coal slag heap
you get a sense of the scale of this
vast flat landscape in eastern ukraine
another shell
explodes
smoke rises from burning buildings in
the distance
a missile is fired towards a target
potentially tens maybe hundreds of
kilometers away
there are hundreds of villages like
these right the way across this region
that seemingly are directly in the line
of russia's potential advance
the russian military control an area
only a few kilometers in that direction
and they are trying to sweep through
here on their way to try and surround
slavyansk meanwhile there are thousands
of civilians in places like this and
they are terrified of the days ahead
charles stratford al jazeera
eastern ukraine